M it's
God it's
God um but you know there was some core
things that like when it comes to Jesus
for example I I understand that you know
the belief is that Jesus is like
Jehovah's you know created son that he
created all things through and stuff
like that like that's that's what it
said in what does the bible teach book
um but like so my my problem with that
obviously you know you guys don't
believe that Jesus is
Jehovah you know you guys don't affirm
that true believe that he is God two
separate yeah two separate beings and
so so one I'm like okay I never got a
chance to study this with them they was
just on the table I picked it up and you
know just and that was that but so how
do you guys I guess
reconcile um I believe it's in Hebrews
like Hebrews one I believe kind of
points out that Jesus is is Jehovah like
in Hebrews 1 it talk it quotes a Psalm
dedicated to Jehovah but says that that
is about Jesus actually have you you
guys know what I'm talking about are you
talking are you talking about perhaps
John no no no not John not John um it's
it's Hebrews one he Hebrews 1 uh: 10 to
12 oh Hebrews 1: 10-
12 tell you know about the Bible yeah I
this is I like to it's my favorite topic
but the Bible is my thing to talk about
oh at the beginning oh Lord you laid The
Fountains of the earth mhm the heavens
are the works of your
hand
uh that is quoting Psalm 102 yeah when
you yeah yes I I I like I said like when
I saw that I you know was I even
remember the chapter it's chapter four
of the what does the bible teach book so
probably still boxed up somewhere but
it's a good book yeah you know I I
enjoyed it um you say this you think
this referring to Jesus yeah yeah yeah
in Hebrews 1 it says that the father is
speaking of the son in verse 8 it says
but of the son he says and so now it's
talking about what the father says about
the son and so the father is saying is
quoting Psalm 102 saying that that's
about the son that he's the Lord who
laid the foundation of the earth Heavens
are the work of his hands and stuff like
that but it's it's it's not those
attributes cuz obviously you guys would
believe that as well like yes he was you
know his master worker and stuff like
that right but specifically this is a
reference to Jehovah himself that like
this the psalm is talking to Jehovah I
think we disagree on that but I get to I
see what you what you're talking about I
think we disagree on that yeah we don't
that we don't think that's referring
to Jesus as Jehova okay so so that's
that's what I asked like how do you how
do you piece that together cuz the psalm
literally like it's it's talking to
Jehovah right and then Hebrews it it
applies that to to Jesus when we get the
sub like many people like I mean who
sincerely believe that Jesus is
Jehovah uh what this is what I do uh I
was talking to another gentleman he had
the Psalms he went
to Revelations then he
went it's like what did Jesus when he
you know he was asked the same question
are you God are you Jesus I mean are you
God this is what he said not what
Hebrews said not not saying that they
disagree we just we just think
differently about the scripture for
instance these my little
notes just we get this conversation all
the time yeah like
okay did Jesus say that he was God or
equ to God John 5:19
now I think it's like 6 7 8 n 10
scriptures what
Jesus is
saying I'm not God in John
5:19 um but I trust it it's
good John 5:19 and 18 they said this is
why the Jews begin that's yeah because
not only in the Sabbath but calling God
his own father making himself equal with
God
519 he 16 or 17 18 Yep this is why the
Jews begin to seeking more to kill him
because not only was he breaking his
Sabbath but he was also calling God his
own father making himself equal to God
now if he's he if he's God then he's
Jesus at the same person he'd be equal
not not the same person but sharing the
same
Essence so like if there there would be
a within God's infinite Essence there is
a plurality of persons in there that's
just what he
reveals this what he said most truly I
say to you the son cannot do a single
thing on his own initiative but only
what he sees the father doing those two
people there there's two persons yeah I
acknowledge so but you got to finish
it whatever the things the one does the
things the sun does also in life man
right the father for the
son so so you see here in John 5:19 it
says Jesus can do whatever the father
can
do it says whatever the father does the
son does likewise yeah you know yeah in
black man not I actually have very uh
many personality types like my dad but
we are also different I was raised by
him and so because as I was raised by my
father and my mother I have um
qualities I have I have so many
qualities I learned many things from my
dad that now I can do yeah
um he said he said he can't do a single
thing by himself so but here's here's
the here's the
thing the son cannot do a single thing
of his own a single thing of his own
initiative yeah like he doesn't work
alone like everything he does is he
always does it with father go ahead two
people I agree he said I can't do a
single thing on my own yeah he doesn't
do it by himself but but we got to
finish it he says but whatever he sees
the father doing for whatever the father
does that the son does like and it's
definitely showing there's two person I
agree but doesn't it show that the two
persons are equal when it comes to their
ability he didn't say he said I can't do
a single thing by himself and neither
and the father doesn't do anything by
himself either right like look so if you
he says the father shows the son all
things that he does
you see look look
look pral manners Bible principles no no
not that one let's go to Let's STI with
five 19 I don't know what else you see
so look look can you go back to the
where you was at yeah there we go so
look so you see how it says right he
doesn't do anything right we already
know that's two persons right he and the
father two different persons and he's
answering that question he yep he's like
don't get attested you know I'm not no
he okay look I like you a
lot wait come on come on come on you say
that no so look he's he's say he's
making a distinction between him and the
father for sure he's like I'm not the
father yes there's two persons you just
said they were the same no they're the
same being the same Essence but there's
so there's a plurality within God's
Essence look so look
look this whole chapter man I I know I
love this chapter look so look he
says but only what he sees the father
doing for whatever the father does that
the son does likewise so whatever the
father does Jesus says he can do it in
the same way if my father can shoot the
free throw I can do that too okay so
he's showing you that he is equal with
the father and ability right he just
said I I'm not equal no he doesn't no so
let's finish no watch watch watch the
father is greater you know you know that
scripture yes John 1428 we'll get that
promise what we talking about listen I I
don't know what we
talking I don't want to be okay no no no
be yourself please this is the best type
of conversation ever I think we just
disagree of course that's fine
I don't see how you can disagree let me
show you okay so you see here it says
for the father has affection for the son
and shows him all things that he himself
does does the father do anything without
the
son yeah personally he just said that he
shows the son all things that he does is
there anything the father does without
the son being involved According To
Jesus I get your point there you feel me
I mean but he according to us created
son ah so that would be the problem then
because then that would mean that he
doesn't show the son all things that he
does that there's something that he that
he did without the
sonre so that would be a contradiction
no no no no he's not saying that
everything I did it the son did too he
said after I created him okay son what I
do I'mma show you everything do come
here right I'mma show you
that see that's not what he say he
doesn't say after this nothing like that
say before it is after it is he says all
things doesn't mean all things after I
created
you really okay all right so let's let's
go to we going disagree okay so let's go
to let's go to my script yeah let's go
to I can't be sitting wait can we talk
about his creation okay so what it talks
about Jesus being created John 13 here
go to John 13 for okay John 1 the sun
yeah but not that though cuz I
understand the interpretation of that
past this man I well you know it's it's
it's deep
We Just Disagree man wait wait wait let
me get you on this one let me get your
interpretation on this one okay and this
and then we'll let it go then we'll let
it go okay so in John
13 not one one I know a lot of people
probably bring that up to you guys all
time I understand yeah so 1 three for me
is all the things came in existence
through him that's part from everyone
that came into exist all right boom so
you see how it says that Jesus it's it's
through him right that everything came
into existence we age that so besides
himself but it doesn't say that it says
everything what we talk about now
man come on
man it don't say accept
himself and say do not say all
things come on AR don't say all things
you of course he did of of course okay
of course my phone number I think you
think he said all think that mean I
created myself no no it doesn't mean
that he created himself it means that he
himself is uncreated he has always been
that's Jehovah that would mean Jesus is
Jehovah no he created
Jesus not according to that everything
that came into existence came into
existence through Jesus everything we
agree no you don't because you think
that Jesus himself came into existence
so that would mean that according to
this verse Jesus would have had to exist
to bring himself in existence like
Jehovah would have to use Jesus to bring
Jesus into existence obviously that
doesn't make he ain't saying I
created no he what that scripture is
saying which I think we just disagree he
created Jesus from Jesus said everything
is going to come into existence I'm
going teach you you're going to be a
master worker and I'm going show you how
to do all these things everything's
going to come existence through
you but now watch cuz cuz I hear what
you're saying trust
me wait here's the last thing on This I
Promise here's the last thing on this
please cuz I hear what you're saying
you're saying that after he created
Jesus he then began to use him to create
everything else I understand what you're
saying you know that talk but here's my
problem cuz that according to the
scripture look it says not even one
thing came into existence without him
not one thing right so that would mean
that he himself
I've always
existed that's that's a given that
everything else come to existence
through you that's not everything else
that's not what the text says that's a
given now but okay I'll go to your verse
now let me see now lost John 14:28 or
something else is it Colossians 1
online here's
one I can't find
mine you
I think
it's what was they messing with Jesus
okay all right you your M oh um the phes
M yeah yeah all the time he answer them
what did Moses teach you
they uh testing whether lawful men okay
okay that's fine what did Moses teach
okay so maybe we get into contact with
her here he he's quoting Genesis Jesus
go however from the beginning of
creation he made them male and female
for this reason a man will leave his
father and mother and the one will be uh
one flesh so that long with two
therefore what God has yoked together
let no man put
a you know he's talking about Jehovah
he's quoting Genesis yeah is he
excluding himself from Genesis of course
look at him wait but so if he's
excluding himself from Genesis that no
no no no he a I'm saying he's saying go
he give credit to god Jehovah he's not
negating himself though right I'm saying
he's giving credit to
God I understand like cuz they they do
that to each other like the father gives
credit to the son the son gives credit
to the to the father he's saying he is
the one who created man yeah from the
beginning he made them male and female
who is he God as he says right not
himself so does is so he wasn't involved
in that the smartest
time if I if I say hey let me show you
how to make this put that screw there do
that do oh no put that this put the
wheels on it all the way okay hey you
did it there is something that says find
the meting you giving me credit oh thank
you okay I build it up but Jesus is
giving Jehovah God credit for he's giv
him credit this how you this how you
know Eng I'm saying it's not at negation
of himself right like yes yes he gives
credit to the father and stuff like that
vice versa but it's not at like he's not
saying I wasn't involved in that as as
well he right he's not saying I wasn't
involved but he's giving I have no
problem with that two two people yeah I
have no problem with that okay this how
you know as you only way man rais fell
good teacher what must I do to her did
Jesus said to him why do you call me
good nobody is good except one and
that's God Alone is Jesus good what he
say he said there's none good but God he
didn't say he's not good is Jesus good
my brother is the information come on is
Jesus
good this Jesus words yeah he doesn't
say I'm not good he's asked him a
question he said why do you call me good
nobody is good except God alone so if
he's calling him good what is he calling
him he saying I ain't good he didn't say
that he didn't say no he didn't say I'm
not good come you say hey you good you
said why you call me good I'm not good
no no he didn't say he said only one
person is good one one is good God alone
so if he's calling him good he's he's
checking his thought do you know what
you're saying because like that's why
I'm asking you is Jesus
good period
stop I think we just going to no you got
to answer this is Jesus good what did
Jesus say he asked the question and he
said said only God is good he answered
his question Jesus asked the question he
answered the question did he not what I
said to you where you at this one he
didn't answer his question no he didn't
well about what I can receive to Jesus
said to him why do you call me good
nobody is good except God alone so
here's my question is Jesus good what
did he say he said only God is good so
if Jesus is good what does that make him
always go
into he disting
disting himself from God no he's
checking the man he's saying do you know
what you're saying when you say this do
you know the implications Jesus did this
all the time he always asked
thought-provoking questions when people
said stuff he didn't deny being good
right even the Bible it says he's
perfect he's he is good he calls himself
the Good Shepherd he is right so Jesus
we we I mean we can agree even though
like we he's good right he's disting
distinguishing himself from God in that
scripture but is he good he's not good
like God so in what way is
he okay so tell me in what in what way
that's why in the previous vers he said
do you not know he created them male and
female he was not talking about himself
I don't think he was negating himself
remember we don't believe that cuz if if
he was negating I'm saying but he was
not talking about himself but not a
negation I understand what you're saying
brother I understand these two different
people I understand that you say they
but so no no so let let me ask you this
when you say that Jesus is good but not
good like God what's the difference in
what way is the father good that the son
isn't he had to learn from but what that
doesn't make that's not about good he's
asking good character what makes the
father what makes Jehovah good in a way
that Jesus is not good what is Jesus
lacking he's not lacking I don't think
he's lacking he's just not like his
father he just said that's the scripture
literally says he's ex the exact imprint
of his nature no no no no he's not
exactly like his
it's five to
tole
okay we do not consent to
to we we always I Vlog and I do I get
conversations with everybody I know but
we really don't consent to be on video
okay no worries no worries but um you
know I appreciate the conversation that
was smooth you come grab and and get the
look at thing well I mean it was genuine
there's nothing at it that was not
genuine here like I'm I'm going to take
this home looking at I'm going to take
this home I did not notice until now
well I saw the camera over there but I
was like okay it's been there for a
while so you sneak over here yeah I
didn't want get I don't want Y spes in
there I think we just disagree that's
fair but I I would tell you this right
now um this was the funnest conversation
I've had all day you had fun yes you
didn't I mean I thought see you I mean
look I look I talked to a Palestinian
dude over there I talked to a group of
Muslims uh I talked to a Jew this
conversation right here was the best one
I had I promise you as the Lord is my
witness okay well it's it's the funnest
one at least we glad we we believe in
Jesus and God in the
Bible so man what a good conversation
I'm going to let you guys know right now
that right there was the best
conversation that I've ever had with a
Jehovah's Witness it was fun the guy had
character it's very charismatic um but
you know unfortunately he wasn't willing
to submit to the scriptures we saw the
parts where he got himself in trouble
immediately ran away from Hebrews 1 um
even with the question about Jesus being
good he you know these are parts that
they got stuck on Jehovah's Witnesses we
got to encourage them to submit to the
scripture and use theirs you can we can
use their scriptures to prove that Jesus
is Jehovah and this is what was an
example of us doing that today so uh
that's a wrap with this we're at UC
Berkeley man we're going to look for
some for some more action later on all
right oh my God logic
[Music]